foreign
[Music]
briefing for Friday December 9th I'm Zoe
Thomas for The Wall Street Journal
have you ever gotten in a car and looked
up directions on Google Maps only to
then check Waze to see if it has a
faster route
well you might not realize the two
services are actually both owned by
Google the units have worked mostly
separately since Google bought ways in
2013. but this week Google's parent
company alphabet said it plans to
combine them what's behind the change
and how will employees and users be
affected joining me to talk through that
is wsj reporter miles Krupa who covers
all things alphabet the high miles
thanks for joining me thanks Zoe so what
do we know about the reasons for
combining maps and ways
so for a long time maps and ways have
basically operated independently
and right now we're in this moment where
the economy is getting worse Google is
facing more pressure as advertising
growth slows down and recently the
Google CEO Sundar pichai has been
talking about how Google might need to
reduce overlap in some products across
the company for instance in the past
Google had Google Play Music and also
YouTube music and they sort of brought
those two things together so ways and
Maps sort of seemed like a natural area
of overlap to reduce Google said some of
the benefits from this move will be that
the teams can work together on their map
making efforts some of these efforts
were being duplicated across both ways
and Google Maps and it doesn't make
sense for those to be kept separate so
you could see it improving efficiency
and potentially also improving costs
down the line if they're able to find
technical costs they can cut by being
able to centralize some of the stuff in
one organization
what is this going to mean for the
people who work in each of these units
then so Google said there won't be any
layoffs associated with this move but
ways workers will be going to a new
organization led by this executive Chris
Phillips who leads Maps Earth street
view under this organization called Geo
so these people who used to work fairly
separately on two products that were in
some ways competing under the same roof
are now going to be I guess in the same
room together not just under the same
roof the idea is that they'll be
collaborating more on things like
navigation how to improve the user
experience on both apps and how to learn
from both apps but I have to think it's
going to be just a little awkward since
they're planning to keep ways as its own
Standalone app and clearly there are
people who are devoted to one or the
other you mentioned that people are
devoted to one or the other I mean there
is somewhat of a divide between people
who use Google Maps to get around and
people who swear by ways to get around
so what is this combination going to
mean for users of these apps
so far I think it will mean very little
for the users they plan to keep ways as
a separate app a separate brand you know
it will be interesting to see how the
ways Community reacts to this because
Waze maintains a very active community
of basically unpaid Freelancers who
crowdsource data about traffic and are
constantly updating the ways navigation
maps so I'm sure people in the community
will have thoughts about these team
members now working with Google Maps
let's take a step back for a second
Google acquired ways in 2013. can you
tell us a little bit about that
combination over time
sure so as you said Google acquired ways
in 2013 for about 1.1 billion dollars uh
it was a big acquisition for the company
at the time it drew some scrutiny from
Regulators worried that Google was
basically eliminating its biggest
competitor in maps But ultimately it was
cleared
for the longest time Waze was led by
this CEO gnome Barton who was sort of
the face of the company the charismatic
leader and based on my understanding he
did a good job of sort of protecting
ways within Google and trying to keep it
as an independent thing in 2021 he
actually left the company and later said
that he thought Waze probably could have
grown faster as an independent company
and kind of hit out at the Google
bureaucracy they brought in a new CEO
last year Neha Parikh plans to exit the
organization after a transition period
the reason Google gave is that because
Waze is no longer an independent
organization it does not need its own
CEO what's still unclear is whether Neha
will stay with Google or alphabet in
some role so we'll have to see where she
lands okay so that's the change to Waze
and to Google Maps but as you you
mentioned this is part of a bigger
strategy for alphabet to deal with cost
cutting I mean do we expect to see more
steps like this at the company
yeah I think we will see more stuff like
this we've already seen Google kill
stadia which was its Cloud streaming
gaming service we've seen it make cuts
at an internal incubator called area 120
. so far it's sort of small stuff around
the edges and I think we're still
waiting for a really big cut but this is
maybe a sign that Sundar and the rest of
the Google leadership is looking for
areas where there are redundancies and
where they want to reduce those
what about Investors how are they
reacting to these steps
so far Google has been much more
cautious than almost all the other big
tech companies and cutting costs and
especially cutting head count so I think
there's a general sentiment among
investors that
the head count of Google is too high
there was an activist hedge fund TCI
that wrote a letter to that effect last
month and I spoke to other shareholders
who basically felt like TCI was sort of
saying the quiet part out loud so I
think what investors really want to see
is a headcount reduction and to be frank
that's just very ungoogly so I think
Sundar and the rest of Google leadership
is grappling with weather and how they
could ever do something like that all
right that's our reporter miles Krupa
thanks for joining us miles thanks Zoe
and that's it for Tech news briefing
this week our producer is Julie Chang we
had editorial support from Falana
Patterson our executive producer is
Chris Tinsley and I'm your host Zoe
Thomas thanks for listening and have a
wonderful weekend
[Music]
[Music]